-Thank you, thank you so much
for coming on.
It's always great to see you.
And I just want
to really thank you,
because this must be hard
for you guys because you lost
one of your founding
members of De La Soul, Dave, not
less than a month ago.
I know this
is a tough time for you,
but you making the trip
to come on our show
and talk to everybody,
and talk about Dave
and talk about De La Soul
means a lot to us,
but also to the fans out there.
This means a lot.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, man.
It's bittersweet, you know?
-It's got to be bittersweet
because you've been trying
to get your stuff
available for years.
-Yeah.
-About a good 15 years.
-I remember having -- we had you
on in "Late Night."
We talked about that with Dave,
and we had you on
"Tonight Show" as well.
I go, "Is it out yet?"
"Jimmy, hold on.
Wait a sec."
We're almost there.
It's coming."
-Almost, yeah.
-"Almost." finally, it's
available on Spotify, anything.
You get De La Soul, type it in,
stream it.
Give it to everybody.
It's finally...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yo.
-Yeah, Dave.
-Dave, they're doing it.
-Yeah, man.
-What do you --
what do you remember
about this debut, the first one?
-I remember me having hair.
[ Laughter ]
-Cutting high school
my last year.
-Is that right?
-To make that record.
-To make this record.
-I was supposed
to graduate in '88.
I ended up graduating in '89
because I cut.
[ Laughter ]
-Because of this.
-To make that record.
-Did you guys --
did you meet in school?
-Yeah.
-Summer school.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-I was trying
to get extra credit.
-Yeah.
-No, he wasn't.
-No, he wasn't. Yeah.
-We were all failing English.
-Yeah.
-We had to take
an English class.
-That's interesting.
That's where you guys met.
-Yeah, yeah, I mean, I've known
Dave through his brother, Mike.
So, by me moving from the Bronx
to Long Island,
met Mike Jolicoeur,
and that's how I met Dave.
Yeah, we just became cool,
and of course,
hip hop just embraced us.
-What school in Long Island?
-Amityville.
-Amityville High School.
Amityville Junior High
and High School.
-Amityville.
Amityville's in the house.
-Yeah, we got some Long Island.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So many people have said this
album changed their life,
including Questlove,
who it changed him.
Quest, how -- how did it
change your life?
-I mean, for the first time,
we just saw, like, ourselves.
This is how, like,
the group bonded, Tariq and I.
We just saw three friends just
having fun with each other,
practical jokes
and all that stuff.
And we had never seen that in
hip hop before.
-Yeah.
-Do you guys feel
like you were being free
when you were making this
and rhyming.
-Definitely, cause we were just
having fun in Mase's basement,
and it literally went from the
basement to the studio
because by the luck of the draw
we have someone
like Prince Paul.
-Yeah, Prince Paul.
-Implemented that freedom.
-Yeah.
-How did you hook up
with Prince Paul?
Just through a label?
-No, he was from Amityville.
-He's from Amityville.
He went from -- yeah.
-Yeah, I used to do a bunch of
parties around Long Island,
and Paul come
from the battle scene.
So, he would come to these
parties and deejay for about
20 minutes,
and do all his tricks
until somebody went
to pop a tape in.
And he would stop, take the
tape, pop it out and leave.
That's how -- that's how, yeah.
-He say don't play my tape.
-You know, he didn't want nobody
biting his tricks.
He didn't want nobody
stealing his tricks.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
And Paul was part of the
legendary group Stetsasonic.
-Yeah.
-And how crazy enough
that they're from Brooklyn,
he's from Long Island.
-Yeah, I didn't know that.
-Yeah, I moved from Brooklyn
to Long Island,
and here it is,
I moved closer to my dream
by meeting Prince Paul.
-What was the basement like?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you remember the basement?
-The basement?
-Yeah, your basement.
-My basement?
Oh, it was very dark.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you have anything
to sit on? What was it?
-We had stuff to sit on because
my uncle made it, like,
a little sanctuary where he
would bring his girlfriends.
and all that.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-It was beautiful.
-But then I took over
with the records
and the equipment.
-And you started taking over.
I have a picture of you guys
back then.
Look at this.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
I refuse to wear those pants.
-Yeah, why didn't you -- why
didn't you wear the pants?
-I wasn't with it, man.
-That was dope though.
-That was our first performance.
Yeah, man.
We were scared.
DMC was right up front,
cheering us on.
-DMC was there.
Jay was there.
-Yeah.
-What?
-Kane was there.
-No.
I wouldn't have --
I wouldn't have gone on.
[ Laughter ]
"You've got to get out of here,
and then let us perform."
And what were they like after
you guys performed?
-They loved it, man.
It was actually Stesasonic's
release party, but we got to
perform at it.
And we did the one song, and I
remember DMC came backstage,
was like,
"Yo, do the song again."
Like, it was just amazing.
-And it was -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was at Urban Plaza, yep.
-Was that Urban Plaza?
-Urban plaza, yep.
-Urban Plaza here in the city.
I know it's been years and years
just legal battles
trying to get this thing out.
I just want to let
everyone know a couple
accolades about this album.
University recognizing one of
the best and most influential
albums in hip hop history.
One of the greatest
albums of all time.
"Rolling Stone" listed as one
of the 200 greatest
hip hop albums of all time
at number 33.
Library of Congress added
the album to the National
Recording Registry for its
for cultural significance.
Since it was released,
it is now -- right now currently
number 15 on the Billboard
200 album chart.
It is back.
De La Soul is back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you guys, and thank you
for playing.
You're going to play
with The Roots tonight?
-Yes, of course.
-"Stakes Is High."
-I would like to thank --
I would like to thank
Reservoir Media for making this
all possible.
-Okay.
-The new owners,
people who actually bought
the catalog who made
the deal extremely right
for us, you know?
-That's awesome.
-And I also want to thank --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also want to thank Dave.
-Want to thank Dave.
-I want to thank Dave.
I want everybody -- can you
please say for me,
"Thank you, Dave?"
-Thank you, Dave!
-Thank you.
-Come on.
Tonight he's watching.
-Yeah, man.
-Check out De La Soul's entire
back catalog available now
on all streaming platforms.